UKRAINE SAYS RUSSIAN FORCES
LAUNCHED 70 MISSILES ON
WEDNESDAY.
51 OF THEM WERE INTERCEPTED.
BUT THOSE THAT DID STRIKE
KNOCKED OUT POWER AND WATER
SERVICE ACROSS UKRAINE AND
KILLED AT LEAST SEVEN PEOPLE.
SEVERAL REGIONS SAY THEIR POWER
HAS NOW BEEN LARGELY RESTORED.
ALSO SLAMMED
INTO A HOSPITAL MATERNITY WARD,
KILLING A NEWBORN BABY.
THE INTERNATIONAL CONDEMNED THAT
ATTACK IN THE ZAPORIZHZHIA
REASON.
SAYING WOMEN AND CHILDREN
CONTINUE TO PAY A HIGH PRICE
FOR THIS FOR.
FOLLOWING THE STRIKES,
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY URGED AN EMERGENCY
MEETING OF THE UN SECURITY
COUNCIL TO SUPPORT THE
UKRAINIAN PEACE FORM.
THAT SAYING THERE SHOULD BE NO
ROOM FOR TERROR IN THE WORLD.
CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE IS IN
SOUTHERN UKRAINE WITH MORE
DETAILS.
NOW ON RUSSIA'S LATEST ASSAULT
ON THE COUNTRY.
>> THE LATEST TARGET IN RUSSIA
'S RUTHLESS MISSILE BARRAGE.
A UKRAINIAN MATERNITY WARD
POUNDED FROM THE SKIES.
EMERGENCY WORKERS PULLING A
DOCTOR AND YOUNG MOTHER FROM
THE RUBBLE.
BUT A NEWBORN BABY, JUST 2 DAYS
OLD, COULD NOT BE SAVED.
TATIANA IS THE GRANDMOTHER NOW
IN UNBEARABLE PAIN.
HER DAUGHTER'S FACE AND LEGS
WERE WOUNDED BY SHRAPNEL SHE
SAYS,, BUT IT IS THE LOSS OF
THE CHILD HAS LEFT HER DAUGHTER
EMOTIONALLY SHATTERED, ANOTHER
LIFE, ANOTHER FAMILY NOW IN
RUINS.
ACROSS UKRAINE, THE ROAR OF
RUSSIAN MISSILES IS TEARING UP
THE SKIES.
NEAR THE CAPITAL KYIV, A
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING WAS HIT
THE YARD OUTSIDE TURNED INTO A
SMOLDERING DISASTER ZONE.
OFFICIALS SAY CASUALTIES ARE
HIGH, WITH DOZENS INJURED OR
KILLED, AS RUSSIA TRIES TO
TARGET ENERGY AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS UKRAINE
IN AN APPARENT DELIBERATE
ATTEMPT TO MAKE PEOPLE HERE
SUFFER.
>> AND ANOTHER OBSTACLE THE
UKRAINIAN LEADERSHIP IS VOWING
TO OVERCOME.
>> TRANSLATOR: THE TASK HAS
BEEN SET, WE WILL RESTORE ALL
OF THIS, AND WE WILL GET
THROUGH ALL OF THIS, BECAUSE WE
ARE AN UNBREAKABLE PEOPLE.
>> BUT WITH POWER OUTAGES
NATIONWIDE, THESE ARE FRAGILE
TIMES.
SHOPS OPERATING BY FLASHLIGHT,
PUBLIC TRANSPORT AT A VIRTUAL
STANDSTILL, AND EVEN HOSPITALS
FAR AWAY FROM THE WAR ZONE ON
EMERGENCY SUPPLIES.
RUSSIA'S BARRAGE MAY NOT HAVE
BROKEN UKRAINIANS, BUT IT IS
MAKING THEM SUFFER.
MATTHEW CHANCE, CNN, ODESSA.
>> BUT LIGHTS ARE NOW BACK ON
AND AT LEAST SOME PARTS OF
UKRAINE FOLLOWING THE MASSIVE
WAVE OF RUSSIAN STRIKES.
OFFICIALS SAY ELECTRICITY HAS
BEEN RESTORED IN 90% OF THE
CITY OF LVIV WITH HEAT AND
WATER SERVICE BACK UP AND
RUNNING.
WILL POWER SUPPLY IS ALSO
COMING BACK IN ODESSA AND IN
THE ZAPORIZHZHIA REGION.
MEANWHILE, A SENIOR WORLD
HEALTH OFFICIAL SAYS MILLIONS
OF UKRAINIAN LIVES COULD BE IN
DANGER THIS WINTER.
THAT'S BECAUSE HOSPITALS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY LACKED POWER AND
FUEL.
WHICH CAN PREVENT THEM FROM
PROVIDING PROPER CARE TO
PATIENTS.
BUT SOME EUROPEAN CITIES ARE
HOPING TO ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEM
BY DONATING POWER GENERATORS TO
UKRAINE.
THEY WILL GO TO KEY FACILITIES
SUCH AS SCHOOLS, HOSPITALS, AND
WATER SUPPLY STATIONS.
AT THE UN, THE U.S. AMBASSADOR
SLAMMED MOSCOW OVER THE ATTACKS
ON UKRAINE'S POWER SYSTEM.
>> COLLEAGUES, IT SEEMS THAT
PUTIN IS DETERMINED IN TO
REDUCE UKRAINIAN ENERGY
FACILITIES TO
MORE CLEAR AND MORE COLD
BLOODED.
HE IS WINTER TO IN
FLECKED IMMENSE SHOWERING ON CNS
FOLLOWING DEVELOPMENTS FOR US.
SHE JOINS US LIVE FROM LONDON.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU ZELENSKYY
IS URGING THE UN SC TO
BASICALLY SUPPORT A PEACE
FORMULA IN THE WAKE OF THESE
LARGE SCALE MISSILE ATTACKS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THIS?
>> YES, SO PRESENT ZELENSKYY
CALLING AN EMERGENCY UN
SECURITY COUNCIL MEETING
YESTERDAY, ROSEMARY.
AND THIS CAME AFTER AROUND 70
MISSILES WERE FIRED BY RUSSIA
TOWARDS UKRAINE, AN ATTACK SO
EXTENSIVE, ROSEMARY, THAT
NEIGHBORING MOLDOVA LOST
ELECTRICITY.
A MAJORITY OF THOSE MISSILES
WERE SHOT DOWN BY UKRAINIANS
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM.
SOME OF COURSE HITTING THEIR
TARGETS.
AND THE RESULT OF THAT WAS
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE UKRAINIAN
ELECTRICITY CONSUMER LOST POWER
TODAY IN THE CAPITAL KYIV, THAT
MEANT THEY ALSO LOST RUNNING
WATER.
SO, HOMES WITHOUT RUNNING WATER,
WITHOUT A RUNNING ELECTRICITY
IN THE COLD OF THE WINTER.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
HOSPITALS, CLINICS,
TRANSPORTATION.
ALL OF THESE KEY BITS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT STRUGGLE TO
FUNCTION OF COURSE UNDER THESE
CONDITIONS.
I WAS IN KYIV A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO, AND WE SAW ESSENTIALLY
DIALYSIS HAD TO STOP WHEN WATER
WAS CUT OFF.
TO A LOCAL HOSPITAL THERE.
SO, PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY CALLING
THIS EMERGENCY COUNCIL MEETING.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> [INTERPRETER]
ENERGY TERROR IS COMPARABLE TO
THE USE OF WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
WHEN WE HAVE THE TEMPERATURE
BELOW ZERO AND SCORES OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WITHOUT
ENERGY SUPPLIES, WITHOUT
HEATING, WITHOUT WATER, THIS IS
AN OBVIOUS CRIME AGAINST
HUMANITY.
>> SO, PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, YET
AGAIN ACCUSING THE KREMLIN OF
TERRORISM.
YET AGAIN ACCUSING IT OF HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
YET AGAIN ACCUSING RUSSIA OF
INFLICTING CIVILIAN SUFFERING
INTENTIONALLY, VERY FAR FROM
THE FRONT LINES AND UKRAINE'S
ALLIES, PRESENT ZELENSKYY'S
FRIENDS, INCLUDING UNITED
STATES, ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
THIS ASSESSMENT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
PROVIDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF SUPPORT, ROSEMARY.
AND THIS ISN'T JUST IN THE FORM
OF WEAPONS IN AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM AND ROCKETS AND BULLETS.
IT'S ACTUALLY COMING IN THE
FORM OF CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO, GENERATORS, TRANSMIT
THERE'S, EQUIPMENT TO FIX POWER
GRIDS.
I KNOW MANY EUROPEAN CITIES ARE
LOOKING AT SENDING ALL THE
GENERATORS AND TRANSMITTERS
WHERE THEY CAN.
THEY LAUNCHED THIS CAMPAIGN,
GENERATORS FOR HOPE, GENERATORS
FOR PEACE.
SO, A REAL MOVE THERE TO
BOLSTER UKRAINIANS CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AHEAD OF THIS
VERY TOUGH WINTER, ROSEMARY.
>> YEAH, SALMA ABDELAZIZ,
JOINING US LIVE FROM LONDON.
MANY THANKS.